si el vídeo anterior se les dificultó
porque tenía demasiada física voy a
resumir rápidamente lo que vimos ahí
vimos el modelo de board el átomo de
hidrógeno y vimos que tiene un protón en
el núcleo aquí está la carga positiva en
el núcleo y un electrón con carga
negativa orbitando al núcleo aún cuando
esto no es algo real el modelo de board
no refleja lo que realmente sucede con
el átomo es un modelo interesante para
analizar suponemos que aquí el electrón
está orbitando en esta dirección en
sentido antihorario que nos da un vector
velocidad tangente a esta órbita y que
denominamos b
en el vídeo anterior y en este vídeo
anterior calculamos el radio y dijimos
que éste era igual a r 1
r 1 es igual a 5.3 por 10 a la menos 11
metros el cual es un número importante
también deducimos esta ecuación la r
para cualquier entero n es igual a n al
cuadrado por r 1 por ejemplo si queremos
calcular nuevamente r 1 este es el
primer radio de acuerdo al modelo de
bolt y es igual a 1 al cuadrado por r 11
al cuadrado es 1 y obviamente r 1 es
igual a r 1 y r1 quedamos que es igual a
5.3 por 10 a la menos 11 metros cuando n
es igual a 1
tenemos un electrón en el estado base el
estado con menor energía posible en el
átomo en el átomo de hidrógeno
hablaremos de los niveles de energía en
el siguiente vídeo así que este de aquí
es un número muy importante es el radio
de la órbita más pequeña en el modelo de
voz en el vídeo anterior también
encontramos una ecuación para calcular
la velocidad del electrón si ve en el
vídeo anterior observarán que la
ecuación que encontramos
la velocidad es igual al entero n
multiplicado por la constante de planck
dividido entre dos pi m&r y redujimos
esto usando la suposición de vor para el
momento angular quant izado y la idea
clásica del momento angular
si ponemos números aquí podremos
calcular la velocidad de este electrón
tomamos este radio lo sustituimos aquí y
ya sabemos cuáles son los otros números
n es aquí igual a 1 así que lo ponemos
aquí la velocidad es igual a 1 por la
constante de planck que es 6.626 por 10
a la menos 34 dividido entre 2 pie por m
y como estamos hablando del electrón m
es la masa de nuestro electrón que es
9.11 por 10 a la menos 31 kilogramos y
finalmente para n igual a 1 nuestro
radio calculado es éste 5.3 por 10 a la
menos 11 metros
si hacemos todos estos cálculos y no lo
haremos aquí para ahorrarnos tiempo
tendremos una velocidad aproximada de
2.2 por 10 a las 6 metros por segundo si
hacen el análisis dimensional estas son
las unidades que deben obtener esta es
la velocidad de acuerdo al modelo de vor
podemos calcular el radio de este
círculo de aquí y también podemos
calcular la velocidad y nuevamente esto
no es algo real pero estos números nos
van a servir en siguientes vídeos y es
importante saber de dónde vienen ese es
el radio de la órbita más pequeña en el
modelo de voz del átomo de hidrógeno
podemos tener otros radios y podemos
calcular esos radios de órbitas más
grandes
usando esta ecuación usaremos diferentes
valores para n
comenzamos con n igual a 1 usamos la
misma ecuación pero ahora con n
igualados vamos a reescribir esta
ecuación aquí abajo y hago más espacio r
para cualquier entero n es igual a n al
cuadrado por r 1 entonces calculemos
este radio cuando n es igual a 2
2 es igual a 2 al cuadrado por ere 1
así que el segundo radio posible es
igual a 4 por r 1 es igual a 4 por r 1
si quisiéramos ver una gráfica este
sería el núcleo de acá estoy acá sería r
1 y el segundo radio permitido sería 4
veces el primer radio así que más o
menos digamos que está por acá y digamos
que este radio es cuatro veces el
primero y es r 2 que es igual a 4 veces
r 1 y así dibujamos el siguiente radio
el siguiente radio permitido usando el
modelo de board podemos calcular
matemáticamente a que es igual esto ya
que conocemos el valor de r 1
qué es 5.3 por 10 a la menos once metros
y si hacemos el cálculo de 4 por este
número nos dan 2.12 por 10 a la menos 10
metros
este es nuestro segundo radio cuando en
es igual a 2 hagamos otro más cuando n
es igual a tres cuando n es igual a 3
este radio sería igual a 3 al cuadrado
por r 1 tomamos este 3 lo sustituimos
aquí y 3 al cuadrado es 9 así que esto
es igual a 9 x r1 nuestro siguiente
radio permitido va a ser 9 veces el
primer radio y seguramente no me va a
quedar escala pero vamos a dibujarlo
aquí que es bastante más grande
este es el rival a 39 veces cr1 y bueno
no voy a intentar dibujar todo este
círculo pero ustedes se dan una idea y
también podemos hacer el cálculo
matemático 9 por 5.3 por 10 a la menos
11 metros nos da aproximadamente 4
puntos 7 7 por 10 a la menos 10 metros
estos son los diferentes radios que
pueden existir usando el modelo de voz
podemos decir que el radio de las
órbitas está cuantificado ya que sólo
ciertos radios están permitidos
no podemos tener algo que se encuentre
intermedio al menos esto no puede
ocurrir de acuerdo al modelo de voz y
cada uno de estos radios está asociado
con un diferente nivel de energía lo
cual es bastante importante y es la
razón por la que estamos haciendo todos
estos cálculos calculamos cada uno de
estos radios y cada uno de estos está
asociado con un nivel de energía que
probablemente es de lo más importante